How's the work going?
Mr. Kishibe,
you'd better concentrate on running.
I've accepted your challenge.
So it's already started.
I won't screw up like last time.
I'll wipe the floor with you.
Kishibe Rohan!
Whoa!
Seventeen point two km/h.
Your body, it's changed, hasn't it?
Your name is Hashimoto Yoma, right?
You're 21, aren't you?
Wow, look at your side muscles.
How did you get like that?
Serratus anterior muscles?
That's not just any old six-pack.
The muscle definition is incredible.
I've never seen anything like that before.
Why don't you just shut up and run?
Now I've passed 18 km/h.
What's that?
The shape of his muscles,
what does this mean!?
Nineteen km/h.
Mr. Kishibe, the last time you quickly
tapped the tablewith your fingers
and made the situation
advantageous for yourself…
so that the remote would fall
into your hand.
It was a borderline case,
and you can't call that a victory.
You can't have ambiguity
in acompetition.
This time you won't get away with it!
Wait a minute, this is just agame.
Yes, what we're doing is just a game.
Just playing around, but it has
to be fair to decide the winner.
Especially for a rematch.
We've gotta decide fairly and squarely.
A rematch has to be done right!
It's just that
you couldn't grab the remote.
Are you calling me a cheat?
I'm just saying,
our game's gotta be fair.
What?!
What the hell is he doing?!
Backwards?
He's running backwards on thebelt?!
At 20 km/h! Running backwards!
Wow, he's in such incredible shape!
But what's he playing at?
Why is he running backwards?!
Hey! What on earth are you…